[Music]
there is only one war that matters and
it is here what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back from my final
season 7 preview trailer breakdown video
we are only a few days away from the
season 7 finale now and I have to admit
it does kind of suck that the season is
almost over
even with all the plot holes this season
I still wish there were more episodes
but this last episode is the longest one
in Game of Thrones history so hopefully
we can go out with the bang so let's
take a closer look at this preview and
find out some of the things we can
expect to see in the finale the trailer
begins with grey worm and the unsullied
standing in formation and they have
finally made it back to the eastern side
of the continent the last time we saw
grey worm he was at Casterly Rock the
unsullied easily took over the castle
because the Lannisters had pulled their
troops out of there and took them to
Highgarden so they could sack a much
more valuable Castle of their own after
grey worm had taken control of Casterly
Rock he saw that he wasn't the only one
there looking for a fight euron greyjoy
showed up and destroyed the unsullied
zone Lee ride back home so I'm assuming
grey worm and his men had to march all
the way back across Westeros as far as
we know Daenerys never sent them any
ships so they could get back and we're
also not sure how many she actually has
left at this point we can see Tyrion on
a ship later in this preview trailer and
he's with Theon and Varys if you look
around the ship you can see the
unsullied shields all over the place so
there is a chance that Tyrion went and
picked them up to take them to the
parlay scene Tyrion did tell Daenerys
that they were going to show up with two
armies and three dragons we have no idea
how much time is passing between
episodes either the unsullied may have
found a way to Dragonstone first and now
they are sailing back to King's Landing
together for the parler scene it's
really hard to say because the timelines
haven't been too consistent but either
way this scene that the dragon pit
should be pretty impressive
there will be over 20 well-known
characters at this meeting your own
Greyjoy has now made it back to King's
Landing as well with his massive fleet
and we should see him with Yara Greyjoy
- she was never put in the cell so I'm
thinking Euron still has her and may use
to bargain with theon greyjoy will also
be here too and I'm still hoping he
plans on getting his sister back now
we're not gonna see any of this until
season 8 but I have always said I think
beyond wolf proof is worth by possibly
killing his uncle urine in an attempt to
save his sister I know he still goes
full recall on us but I'm just praying
that one day he's gonna snap out of that
and do something heroic for his sister
Yara they are keeping them alive for
some reason so I hope this is why the
Dothraki also show up for the parlay now
Daenerys will have her entire army in
front of Cersei Daenerys will also show
up with her dragons and she will flex
her muscles in front of Cersei letting
her know exactly what she is up against
but knowing Cersei she probably won't
even flinch Jaime and Bronn are there
overlooking Danny's forces and they know
exactly what they are capable of it
almost appears as if Jaime and Bronn are
at Highgarden they are high up on top of
what looks like some castle walls but
the dragon pit does sit on Rainey's hill
when King's Landing so this is most
likely where they are all at it really
wouldn't make much sense at this point
in this season for them to be anywhere
else
there is also a scene with songs of
standing atop the castle of Winterfell
overlooking the battlements it appears
that she has came up here to reflect on
some of the things that are going on in
the north or perhaps she is planning her
next move her and Arya are on the verge
of killing each other and Littlefinger
is behind it all we just need the stark
sisters to wake up and snap out of this
and realize what is going on I know a
lot of you have been saying that the
stark sisters are actually playing
Littlefinger but that is not the case my
friends never and I mean never
underestimate Littlefinger he has been
playing this game for years and he plays
it very well he is spinning these girls
in circles right now but there is one
thing from the season 7 trailer that has
yet to play out in the trailer we can
hear Songz's say the lone wolf dies but
the pack survives
I believe Arya and Sansa will settle
their differences and I think Sansa says
that quote - Arya or she might even say
it the Littlefinger right after she
sentences him to death Littlefinger will
die in this episode and I believe Psalms
I came up here to think about what she's
going to say to Littlefinger
or this is sanso coming up here right
after Littlefinger is killed the
scene shows Theon collapsing on the
beach and I'm thinking this might be
right after the parler scene he will see
his uncle you're on there and perhaps
his sister's gonna be there too Euron
will probably parade Yara through the
dragon pit and Theon will know that
there is nothing he can do about it at
that time he knows he left his sister
behind when Euron had the knife to her
throat and when he sees Yara stolen
chains being taken away by Euron again
after the parler scene it's gonna tear
him up inside
Theon's gonna need to get someone on his
side willing to help him to try and get
her back before Euron ends up killing
her Daenerys is gonna want her back also
but your honors are gonna want to give
her up without getting something in
return and we all know what he wants but
Daenerys is never gonna give him that so
they're gonna have to get Yara back by
force and I'm hoping Theon can kill
you're on and the process the trailer
ends with everyone arriving at the
dragon pit and like I said before there
will be around 20 or more characters
that we know and I am very excited to
see this scene and to see this big of a
cast at the same place at the same time
this is going to kind of remind me of
the very first episode when the Starks
were all in Winterfell and King Robert
Baratheon showed up with all the
Lannisters only this time they're all
going to be meeting under very different
circumstances so much has happened since
then it kind of blows my mind
Jon Snow is just a bastard boy heading
off to the wall to spend the rest of his
life with the Nights Watch now he is
king in the north but this season has
revealed so much more than that he is a
legitimate Targaryen and rightful heir
to the Iron Throne in Tyrion was just an
alcoholic
imp who loved to sleep with [ __ ] now
he is the hand of the Queen to his
family sworn enemy Jaime Lannister was
just a cocky mother effer back then and
he was seen as the best swordsman in all
the lands but now that sword hand is
gone and he has definitely been humbled
many times due to all of his life
experiences since then I'm getting
emotional just thinking about everything
that has happened since this show first
started but I'm also very excited to see
all these characters come together
before they all end up killing each
other as they all walk into the dragon
pit you can see Cersei and Jaime is
there Tyrion is there bran is there
leading the group in John is there Plus
Podrick Theon Jorah Davos Brienne
missandei and it looks like the Hound is
all the
way in the back with this head turned to
the side the last time we saw the hound
he was loading the white up into the
boat at the wall and they brought the
white all the way down here to show
Circe that the threat is real hoping
they can put aside their differences and
stop fighting each other in order to
fight the common enemy who now has a
dragon of his own
there was another scene from the trailer
that we have yet to see and that was the
Hound letting the white out of the crate
that's right there behind him they will
show sir see exactly how menacing these
things are and they're also going to
demonstrate how exactly hard they are to
kill you can't just kill these things
with any regular old steel the mountains
should be here too since he is Circe's
personal bodyguard and it's gonna be so
much fun to see the Hound in the
mountain and the same scene together
again I wish we could see cleganebowl
but since this is a parler scene there's
probably gonna be a momentary peace
treaty while they discuss terms so I
don't think we're gonna see anyone
fighting in this dragon pit but I would
love it if they did they did not show
Daenerys in this preview trailer either
which I thought was interesting she will
be at the parlay scene with everyone
else but she's gonna make her grand
entrance by showing up last with her
dragons she will flex her muscles in
front of Cersei but Cersei will notice
she is showing up with only two dragons
which should boost Circe's confidence
the night King has made her job so much
easier by taking one of the dragons
Cersei will not take this threat as
serious as everyone else because her
focus is still going to be on King's
Landing in the throne while John and
Danny are focusing on the army of the
Dead Cersei will be using her new goal
to beef up her army and navy although it
seems like season eights gonna focus on
the night king the party is just getting
started between Cersei and Daenerys this
parlay is going to go as well as John
and Daenerys had hoped I just hope that
Cersei will see the light at some point
next season an offer to help or else
Vasari on died for nothing this is the
end of the preview trailer but I will be
making another video and I will talk
about some of the other things that will
happen in this finale that this trailer
did not show the final episode is called
the dragon in the wolf and we're gonna
be finding out some more details about
why the episode is called that but I'm
gonna save that for the next video so I
hope you all come back for that one too
thank you all so much for checking out
my preview trailer breakdown video for
the season 7 finale and as always I have
to thank you wonderful people who
support the
channel 1 patreon I really appreciate
your generosity I hope you all have a
great day bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you